[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París el programa semanal de
radio Francia internacional en
colaboración con la televisión Franz 24
en español constructor de percusiones
latinas compositor autor intérprete
nacido en Lima y con una amplia carrera
Musical Hoy recibimos en esta escala en
París a Rodolfo Muñoz Gracias Bienvenido
a su música gracias por la invitación
gracias a r font español pues un placer
estar aquí y espero que pasemos un lindo
momento musical de amistad y de
hermandad
Pues estamos escuchando la más reciente
de sus obras el país de ayer el vuelo de
la gaviota en que se inspiró para este
trabajo tan interesante bueno es una
producción hecha por una compañía que se
llama tamboricanto en el cual el
director artístico musical es Simón
bolsinger que me invita me invita a
músicos percusionistas en general de
América Latina que hemos tenido pasión
de recibir aquí y que hace un trabajo de
de un puente entre la tradición en la
música de nuestro continente como el su
país la Francia como él es un gran
pianista de jazz
él sabe hacer una cocina entre esos dos
universos y el trabajo efectivamente
Ustedes han escuchado este álbum en el
país del ayer que es un tema muy lindo
Porque la historia es que es una es una
melodía inglesa que luego
cantaba por españoles popularizada por
españoles y que Simón seguro que la idea
de poder también poder viajar con la
música es hacer un nuevo arreglo y
ponerlo a la salsa o a las dos como se
dice a la salsa de tambor y canto con la
percusión como base rítmica y la armonía
y los arreglos y todo Rodolfo Naciste en
Perú ahí fuiste hiciste tus primeros
estudios en percusiones en música afro
peruana Cómo influyó esto en tu carrera
después bueno estudios es mucho decir o
sea la percusión tradicional se aprende
con maestros O sea yo he tenido muchos
maestros que me han dado esa transmisión
oral que que yo he recibido desde mi
Perú en Perú al comienzo porque soy
peruano de Lima luego Viajé a Cuba
seguía con esa tradición oral trabajar
siempre la percusión porque soy
percusionista pero no me quede nada más
que en eso en la percusión tradicional
sino cuando comencé a viajar
comencé a agrandar mi espectro musical
la composición los arreglos luego vine a
Francia estudié en una escuela de jazz y
lo que pasa es que
nuestra como yo todo mi mundo sonoro
efectivamente son las percusiones de mi
país luego hablo mucho de cuba porque en
Cuba pasé muchos años trabajando la
música afrocubana la percusión Y
actualmente hoy día Nosotros somos
Estamos aquí en este en Francia y
nuestro las oportunidades que tenemos
hay que saberlas llevar porque Mostrar
nuestra cultura con la cultura del jazz
o con la cultura francesa con la música
clásica yo soy muy abierto a todo
es lo más importante de poder hermandad
nuestras culturas y poder llegar a un
resultado como la música no este ir y
venir entre Cuba y Perú vamos a decir
entre el Caribe y el Pacífico también lo
decía pasó por la enseñanza de las
percusiones cubanas Qué diferencia hay
entre la percusión eventualmente en Perú
y la percusión cubana Yo sé que en Cuba
usted estuvo estudiando también con el
batán este famoso tambor
Qué efectos tuvo esto primeramente un
mundo rápidamente la percusión
afroperuana yo hablo porque estamos
hablando de la llegada de los españoles
es una percusión muy muy linda muy
simple es el cajón la quijada y la
cajita por ejemplo son tres instrumentos
que son vamos a decir son instrumentos
reciclables no en la costa de Perú no
había la fauna y la flora a esa época
para que el africano pueda reconstruir
sus tambores tampoco no tiene la
oportunidad de hacerlo pero crearon las
cajas el embalaje de la de la que venía
en las carabelas comenzaron a utilizarse
para hacer percusión el embalaje de
madera recuperaba y comenzaron a hacer
percusión enseguida
el el luego este instrumento que se
llama
me aburrió que está aquí que es una es
un instrumento muy creativo en el
sentido que
[Aplausos]
esa Este instrumento que es oriundo de
la cultura afroperuana se puede decir
que es una creación también muy simple
porque a recuperar la parte esta parte
de la mandíbula de la del burro el el
afro peruano comienza a encontrar su
nuevos instrumentos que no ha podido no
pudo reconstruir directamente no
entonces en Cuba lo que pasa que
primeramente al Caribe
desaparecieron casi todos los indígenas
y la llegada masiva de los de la cultura
africana era mucho más importante que en
el Perú entonces Cuba Sí llegaron a
reconstituir sus tambores o sea los
tambores batá de la música Yoruba la
música que viene Nigeria y benig ellos
si comenzaron a reconstruir rápidamente
sus tambores y eso fue lo que la gran
diferencia es que a comparación del Perú
que no pudieron Reproducir todos sus
tambores y por eso que hay una gran
diferencia de instrumentos y luego
efectivamente El Perú El afro peruano no
no era más no era masiva la cultura
africana El Indio fue también
finalmente entonces fueron minoritarios
y luego efectivamente Lo que pasa que en
el Caribe llegaron muchas muchas
culturas africanas no y recogieron
muchos tambores los Yoruba los congos
los carabalí los bantú o sea es una
historia Rodolfo lo decías antes de
instalarte en Francia definitivamente
hace 20 años más de 20 años que estás
instalado acá hiciste estudios de bosar
justamente aquí en París qué es lo que
sacaste como lección de eso qué es lo
que te aportó para la música para tu
carrera como percusionista Wow linda
pregunta porque esa esa parte de mi vida
fue yo pasé cinco años en la escuela de
Bellas Artes de París estudiando
arquitectura y la la unión que hice
entre la arquitectura y la música es una
cosa muy simple lo que se puede decir la
medida
la medida la misión es la medida
exactamente entre de esos dos mundos ese
y lo que más me gustó en la arquitectura
fue que
a través de la civilizaciones de la
nacimiento del hombre hasta hasta hoy
día es tiene un paralelo el hombre nace
y nace la humanidad y nace rápidamente
La música y pero Y eso siempre estuvo en
mi en mi cuerpo en mi espíritu en mi
manera de pensar como yo puedo a través
y lo veo la composición también porque
cuando construyó me han dicho que
construyó tiene una manera muy
arquitectural sea de Cómo componer o
Cómo traducir la música con toda la
experiencia que vive en la escuela de
Bellas Artes a ese propósito estamos
escuchando ahora otro de los álbumes
producidos por ti que le brello con
ritmo de rap latino una construcción
bastante sofisticada llena de
simbolismos me parece eso es lindo
Porque esa invitación también de Billy
reloj que es una
tiene una pluma muy linda y me llama
porque quería ella tiene dos un dos es
Franco peruana también esa manera de de
de Yo soy abierto como te dije al
comienzo he hecho he trabajado con
música contemporánea con jazz con teatro
con y este este última produce Esta
última producción me encanta porque yo
hice un batel como se dice en largo con
un DJ productor hicimos en este con y
eso me me encanta a mí porque los
reencuentros es lo que vas a evolucionar
nuestra nuestras pasiones y comprender
el mundo de cada uno no hay que
encerrarse no hay que estar esta
encerrado Y eso es importante para mí
porque yo abro llevo con todo mi baja y
cultural Ellos tienen su bagaje y ese
reencuentro esos puentes que los que se
llaman que lo yo los llamo cantos de ida
y vuelta como dicen los gitanos porque
la música flamenca por ejemplo llegó al
América luego efectivamente el tango la
rumba la jibiri esas cosas el gitano se
la propia eso me encanta A mí que cada
que cada cultura pueda reencontrar su
momento dado compartir y el resultado ya
los usar un recorrido bastante amplio
has participado también en una cosa que
cualquier amante de la música conoce que
es el gotan project una cosa muy
innovadora enormemente innovadora para
la música y muy que ha marcado América
Latina en qué influyó este proyecto en
el cual participaste con proyecto
justamente yo encontré yo conocí a
Cristo Miller en la escuela de Bellas
Artes estudiando aquí en París y él era
en esa época él está estudiando también
historia del arte y ese reencuentro
cuando estábamos jóvenes estábamos
jóvenes
y comenzamos a hacer un grupo musical al
comienzo y luego yo viaje a Cuba él
cuando vine mi Rodolfo tengo un nuevo
proyecto se llama agotan cuando fui Guau
él es la cabeza pensante es el culpa de
toda la programación musical electrónica
eran tres entonces se da músico también
o simplemente
para la parte de la programación y me
dice hagamos un proyecto juntos y yo le
digo Mira tengo esto esto esto Yo
componía hace tiempo y luego me dijo
perfecto Rodolfo vamos a unirnos
comenzar a componer juntos y llegamos lo
que pasa es que él viene de un mundo de
la música electrónica él es suizo y tú
sabes que en Suiza en Alemania la música
electrónica es como la como el jazz el
jazz nace en Estados Unidos la música
electrónica tiene una fuente muy fuerte
en una base muy fuerte en estos países y
el reencuentro entre un percusionista
era el Juan escuchó Esto me dijo vamos
por eso que el disco se llama radio que
era enamorado y como había una buena una
buena claro como había una buena amistad
y una buena un buen feeling entre los
dos llegamos cuando salió el álbum la
bbc de Londres esto yo no me esperé pero
sí lo que más me gustó que aquí hay
muchos amigos que grabaron y que esta
música fue peruana la época había Susana
vaca que viajaba mucho y se llegó a un
poco más la música afro peruana la
música que existe de gracias al aporte
de la cultura africana del Perú y eso es
importante fue muy importante mi carrera
también Rodolfo el tiempo se va volando
Lamentablemente Una última pregunta has
participado en festivales evidentemente
en Francia en Europa en Perú en África
sabiendo que cada experiencia es
distinta cuál te ha marcado más la de la
de la de la de bamaco efectivamente me
marcó mucho porque cuando fuimos al
festival de yasa bamaco con tambor y
canto y la compañía de del director
artístico Simón bolsinger
fuimos recibidos por Jake y por Paco
cerri y terminamos comiendo un mixui en
la casa de salita para mí cocida en la
tierra
eso fue o sea yo pasé una semana
haciendo música fuimos a los talleres de
hablar talleres de música también de
nuestra cultura a
y después terminamos comiendo
fue Mali fue la música africana sin duda
Para mí fue lo que muchas cosas lindas
vivido en el mundo en todos los viajes
entonces pero eso fue muy muy lindo y
también que la de la otra fue cuando
tocamos con radio quijada el festival
bomba de hace a unos cuantos años
tocamos mucho antes era antes de
un musangare y cuando terminamos es el
gran organizador Peter Gabriel de este
festival yo terminé terminé de escuchar
hicimos el concierto radio quijada y
luego escuchamos quedé así porque ese
continente siempre con yo siendo
percusionista representando esto la
música afro peruana mi sueño era África
y cuando fui por la primera vez fui a
Mali y en Mali como todo país africano
de la Sub ecuatorial hay mucha hay mucha
información para nosotros Yo estaba
volviendo a nacer rumbo tambor y canto
podríamos decir como mencionó el poeta
peruano estamos llegando ya al final de
esta escala en París el tiempo se ha ido
volando no me queda sino agradecerte
Rodolfo Muñoz el habernos acompañado en
esta escala en París Muchas gracias
a usted Gracias a ti Braulio gracias a
todo el equipo técnico Espero que no sea
la última invitación porque como te dije
tengo estoy terminando un nuevo álbum ya
como otra vez como compositor Pero
dentro de otro registro ya les contaré
la próxima volveremos a ustedes Muchas
gracias por su atención nos vemos aquí
la próxima semana en otra escala en
París
[Música]